em 2008
satoshi nakamoto inventou um sistema
inovador de transações monetárias
digitais chamado bitcoin esse sistema
ficou famoso por não depender de nenhum
banco ou vendo alguém tirar de central
para funcionar
satoshi apenas um pseudônimo até hoje
ninguém sabe a real identidade dessa
pessoa
isso deu origem a muitas lendas surgiram
vários candidatos dizendo ser satoshi
surgiram também lendas de que só poderia
representar um grupo de pessoas em vez
de uma única pessoa e hoje eu vou
apresentar para vocês uma história que
vocês podem adicionar esse repertório de
lendas
essa história se passa em um antigo
vilarejo da china imperial esse vilarejo
ele continua até os dias de hoje
satoshi seria um cidadão chinês chamado
i que vive nos dias de hoje
nesse vilarejo esse vilarejo é na época
da china imperial muito tempo atrás
antes da época de era um vilarejo que
apesar de muito próspero e produtivo era
distante dos principais centros de
economia da época devido a ele ser muito
distante do centro de economia da época
eles tinham dificuldade para ter acesso
a dinheiro uma produção de trabalho
gerava uma única nota joão que era paga
para aqueles trabalhadores que
trabalhavam por exemplo 111 o
treinamento agrícola porque isso
acontecia os mercadores alegavam como o
dela vilarejo era distante eles tinham
muita dificuldade muitos custos com o
transporte
apesar do vilarejo ser autossuficiente
essa falta de acesso ao dinheiro vivo
essa falta de acesso às notas em papel
moeda e prejudica a economia do vilarejo
por quê
essa pessoa juntasse algumas notas e
quisesse comprar uma casa
não tinha problema nenhum o problema é
se a pessoa quisesse comprar uma pessoa
na rua como ela ia fazer céu a separar
essa nota em duas rasgadas a nota deixa
de ser válida
então não era possível é fazer pequenos
pagamentos pequenos comércios no
vilarejo o usuário também não podia
imprimir seu próprio dinheiro nem usar
outros materiais preciosos como moeda
porque o governo da china imperial
ele era muito orgulhoso de ter unificado
todas as moedas da china e disse ter
sido o primeiro governo do mundo a
inventar o papel moeda
então o magistrado que governava o
vilarejo é surgiu com uma solução e
administraria um sistema de títulos de
posse de dinheiro o que eram esses
títulos de posse de dinheiro
eles eram muito similares ao cheques que
já existiam na época eram usados pelos
árabes
esses títulos de posse de dinheiro eles
nada mais é do que um papel que tinha o
destinatário do dinheiro a pessoa que
receber o dinheiro o montante que
poderia ser fracionado quanto quisesse
resolver o problema o problema como eu
faço para pagar um milésimo do ano
não escrevo a um montante que eu quiser
não precisa ficar limitado a uma nota de
ampla unidade mínima e teria uma
assinatura de quem fez o pagamento como
eram apenas títulos de posse de dinheiro
ele não trabalhava com uma casa da moeda
o governo é do império não veria esse
sistema como uma afronta à sua moeda
porém é a maioria da população tinha
muito pouco dinheiro vivo em mãos quando
muito eles tinham uma única nota de um
ano eles não iam confiar deixar essa
nota é confiada a um magistrado então o
magistrado não conseguiriam operar como
um banco
então o que ele fez ele distribuiu um
título especial de inauguração para cada
habitante da vila valendo um íon
só que ele deixou muito claro esse
título que eu dei pra vocês eu não vou
tocar para vocês por dinheiro eu não vou
trocar por uma nota de joan se vocês me
trouxeram esse título
se vocês quiserem trocar
orleans vocês vão negociar com terceiros
então ele distribuiu esse dinheiro e mas
é esse sistema não era um problema
esse sistema dele trabalhar com o
dinheiro que teria que ser trocado com
terceiros porque a intenção dele era com
era a intenção dele era aquecer a
economia do vilarejo em vilarejo
negociava muito pouco com mercadores
freqüência com que eles negociaram
mercadorias é muito baixa então se ele
conseguisse ao que é aquecer a economia
da vila
ele conseguiu alcançar o objetivo dele
pra ele conseguia aquecer a economia da
vila ele antecipou como a população era
muito desconfiada que ele teria que
fornecer um sistema rígido de auditoria
não bastaria ele ter uma tabela com o
saldo de cada habitante
se não ele poderia ser acusado de ter
acrescentado tirado dinheiro de alguém
como ele resolveu isso ele criou dois
livros o primeiro livro ele anexava todo
título que era levado até ele
então aqueles títulos que tinham para a
montante ea assinatura de quem está
pagando assim que uma pessoa recebesse
um título de alguém ela tinha que levar
para o magistrado o magistrado ea
verificar se esse título tinha fundos e
depois disse o ex ao livro e se livrará
público qualquer pessoa poderia chegar
numa estrada e pedir pra conferir esse
livro
depois apenas como uma forma de lhe
poder trabalhar mais rápido ele tinha um
livro de índice esse livro funcionava
como um rascunho ele tinha uma sessão
dedicada a cada habitante do vilarejo
dentro da seção de cada habitante do
vilarejo tinha cada título que a pessoa
recebeu em qual página do primeiro livro
ela poderia ser encontrada e tinha
alecsandro também todos os gastos que a
pessoa fez todos os títulos que ela
emitiu e ele a preenchendo esse índice
de cima para baixo com todos os gastos
correspondentes a cada título assim
conseguir verificar rapidamente se a
pessoa tinha ou não fluidos e sistema
ficou muito famoso na vila resolveu o
problema de fracionamento de dinheiro e
rapidamente ávila alcançou muito
a confiança nesse sistema então era
fácil encontrar um estabelecimento que
aceitasse um sistema de títulos e era
fácil também trocar um título de um ano
um amplo uma nota de um ano até que
ocorreu um problema com esse sistema um
marceneiro muito famoso na vila tinha
realizado um grande serviço por um
comerciante local e devido a isso ele
tinha recebido um título desses
comerciantes com grande valor dinheiro
alguns meses depois ele tentou comprar
um terreno com esse título e ele
preencheram um título com os fundos que
ele tinha para o dono do terreno
só que para surpresa dele no dia
seguinte o dono do terreno voltou com o
título falando o título não possui a
fundos
ele achou aquilo muito estranho porque
ele tinha certeza que o título que ele
havia recebido do comerciante entregado
para o magistrado tinha dinheiro
suficiente para ele comprar aquele
terreno então ele pediu para o
magistrado para conferir o conteúdo dos
livros
só que depois de muito procurar nos
livros ele não encontrou um título que
ele tinha entregue ao magistrado
o magistrado disse se é que você
entregou esse título pra mim ele não tá
aqui no livro não sei o que aconteceu eu
acho que você não deve ter entregue esse
título era pra outra pessoa
ele também foi o comerciante reclamou
que o dinheiro não tinha sido
efetivamente recebido por ele mas uma
comerciante disse não já só de minha
dívida com você então essa história
correu vilarejo um problema não foi
resolvido começou a gerar uma
desconfiança as pessoas pararam de
confiar nesse sistema de tiros pararam
de utilizar mas um professor da vila
começou a pensar nesse problema e daí
surgiu uma idéia ele achava o sistema de
títulos muito interessante é ele queria
que esse sistema continuar sem ele tinha
uma idéia de como fazer esse sistema
ficar de fato seguro
alguns anos atrás esse professor tinha
sido o centro de uma grande polêmica por
abordar o problema de como verificar se
os alunos dele tinham lido um livro que
tinha passado como lição de casa uma
forma um pouco de didática como ele
fazia isso
ele tinha inventado um sistema de
cálculo em um a barco em que ele
associava a cada letra do dicionário
chinês uma seqüência de movimentos de um
ábaco então é ele começava com água com
uma posição inicial cada letra era lida
do texto o aluno tinha que fazer um
movimento correspondente aquela letra
isso era feito de forma que o aluno
trocasse ordem de ler de qualquer letra
ou se esquecesse de fazer os movimentos
correspondência uma letra o número lhe
do abba com o final do processo era
completamente diferente do que seria
lido quase caso ele tivesse passado
corretamente por todas as letras do
livro o número que era lido ao final
desse processo é um número grande tinha
cerca de 15 algarismos
por causa disso era muito difícil você
chutar um número e acertar sem ter lido
o livro e feito corretamente processo
como esse processo o professor julgava
que era muito mais eficiente do que
pedir por um aluno é escrever um resumo
do livro já que ele teria certeza que o
aluno não pulou em uma parte do livro ea
pele dois processos de cálculos de
resumo o professor imaginou que se uma
pessoa quando entregasse um título para
o magistrado calculasse o resumo daquela
página do livro que contivesse o título
ele poderia guardar o número de pois
saberia se aquela página foi alterada ou
não por isso não ainda não resolveu o
problema porque seria a palavra do
magistrado com a palavra da pessoa
exatamente igual no caso do marceneiro
então ele pensou em uma forma de
resolver esse problema
como ele tinha que resolver tinha que
pensar em uma forma de verificar o
resumo de uma página sem um processo
muito rápido bom de fato isso era pra
você passar todas as letras de uma
página no a banco
demorava em média 1 minuto só que ele
queria que caso você é fosse gerar um
resumo para uma página que o processo
fosse muito demorado
de forma que se uma pessoa fosse alterar
uma página ou forjar uma versão
falsificada de uma página se demorasse
muito então ele pensou o seguinte se eu
colocar algumas letras sorteadas no
começo da página no cabeçalho antes
ritos e considerar isso como o conteúdo
da página na hora de passar os letras no
ábaco é cada vez que essas letras forem
sorteados por um valor diferente cada
vez que alterar suas letras eu vou ter
um número diferente se eu considerar uma
página válida somente caso esse número
tenha 12 dígitos são mesmo menos com
essa situação uma raridade a maioria das
páginas a 15 dígitos do ao banco
então uma pessoa sozinha demoraria cerca
de dois dias para fazer esse processo
porém se ele tivesse 50 pessoas
trabalhando em conjunto o tempo para
realizar esse processo seria reduzido
para apenas uma hora
em resumo se eu tivesse 50 pessoas
trabalhando junto para atestar a
autenticidade de uma página do livro
elas conseguiram fechar essa página
gerar um número garantir a autenticidade
daquela página garantir que pelo menos
50 pessoas olhar um conteúdo daquela
página tiveram ciência do conteúdo
aquela página
porém uma pessoa sozinha tentando forjar
uma página levaria dois dias para forjar
aquela página
mais que isso ele percebeu que se ele
colocasse em cada página
no cabeçalho além das letras sorteadas o
resumo da página anterior
ele tem ele teria um tempo cada vez
maior que seria necessário para uma
pessoa conseguiu forjar uma página
conforme mais antiga fosse a transação
então suponho que uma transação tivesse
na antepenúltima página teria que ser
forjada também a penúltima página última
página
para isso seriam necessários seis dias
por uma pessoa trabalhando sozinha
só que restava um problema como ele
faria para que as pessoas que trabalha
trabalhariam é melhorando a segurança do
sistema trabalhar em uma textura
autenticidade das páginas deste livro
como ele faria para recompensar essas
pessoas uma vez que essas pessoas teriam
que ficar o dia inteiro trabalhando em
ambos teriam que deixar seus empregos
originais
bom então ele adicionar uma terceira
informação no cabeçalho da página
seria uma pessoa que ganhariam um valor
de 0,1 joan é devido até achado as
letras que fariam com que
uma página tivesse um número válido
dessa forma ele gerava uma inflação
controlada na economia e recompensar as
pessoas que ajudavam atestar a
autenticidade do sistema um sistema
ficou muito famoso até hoje ele é
conhecido naquele vilarejo funcionou
muito bem depois de adotadas as idéias
do professor
ele só deixou de ser adotado conforme
foi entrando mais papel-moeda na vila
conforme as pessoas foram conseguindo
entrar com mais um ano antes em dinheiro
vivo na vila porque os pessoas que
trabalhavam nos abusos começaram a
adquirir lesões por esforço repetitivo
ou é bom até que na nossa lenda nos dias
de hoje nós temos e que seria o nome
real de satoshi um hábito crypton logo
programador e percebeu que esse cálculo
poderia ser vez realizado por abacus
poderia ser realizado por computadores
eu seria muito rápido não geraria ler
nas pessoas
além disso os computadores conseguem
fazer cópias digitais praticamente sem
custo
então ele conseguiria ter múltiplas
cópias desse livro de registro de
transações praticamente de graça em
todos os computadores do mundo
além disso em vez de exigir a assinatura
sem títulos
ele poderia usar as assinaturas digitais
um processo que é consolidado e
reconhecido pela comunidade de cristo
álbuns desde 1977
a tecnologia utilizar é criada por
satoshi a tecnologia é que ele chamou de
blocos chen seria o equivalente a esse
livro de registros da nossa lenda
ela abre portas para a cidadania digital
qualquer um pode contribuir para atestar
a autenticidade desse livro de registros
que ele chamou de blocos em qualquer
pessoa com um computador
então imagine quantas aplicações você
não tem um sistema capaz de dar
segurança de atestar a autenticidade de
um livro de registros públicos
nós poderíamos ter diversas registros
como títulos de propriedade de terra
contratos que hoje nós registramos em
cartório nós poderíamos
um análogo digital pra esses documentos
que não deveriam não dependeriam da
confiança em uma única entidade no caso
do cartório para funcionar dependeriam
de toda uma rede de pessoas que estão é
tomando ciência desses documentos e
atestam a autenticidade deles então como
é que você faz para participar dessa
revolução como você faz para participar
desse processo de cidadania digital
então baixe programas que utilizem blog
chin
assim como naquele vilarejo é a
confiança é nesse sistema importante
depende de você confiar nesse sistema
para que ele seja aceito por pessoa seja
utilizado
imagine quantas aplicações nós tivemos
aí recentemente as eleições é os
boletins de urnas que se ainda os
boletins de urna que saem da urna
poderiam ser testados por esse sistema
também as aplicações são inúmeras
então eu convido vocês a participar em
se manter informados e baixarem
aplicativos que utilizem bock chan
[Aplausos]